welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm excited to be joined by carl
gallagher who is the associate director
at this is prime
kyle joined the business straight out of
university as a resourcer
and over the last six years he has
climbed the ranks and progressed all the
way up to
associate director where he now sits on
the board
of the business and is responsible for
leading new growth areas in the business
such as
the us and other uk regions carl welcome
back
to the podcast thank you for having me
always a pleasure thank you
amazing so for those of you that haven't
listened cole was involved in the 15
minutes with a mental series but
on this episode we're going to really
dig into carl's journey
so far but where i always like to start
and the first question i have for you
carl
is in your opinion what characteristics
and traits do you think make up a
highly successful recruitment consultant
yes where the where do we start how long
have we got so
there are loads out there and i'm sure
uh we've all heard a lot of the typical
buzzwords that people
tend to say time for this question i
think it boils down to a few main things
to me
first of all you have to be coachable
any person
looking to be successful in this role
you have to be willing to learn and take
on board feedback
and more importantly implement it
straightaway so i think being coachable
is absolutely key and i think someone
that's
solutions focused and so i know there's
a few people recently have spoken a lot
about people who are
curious and inquisitive i think that's
really really important as well to be
successful in recruitment just naturally
wanting to solve problems
and then these two kind of tie in
together but people are incredibly hard
working
of course is absolutely key to being
successful
but people that just know what they want
so
having that real big deep motivation i
don't think it really matters too much
what that is
as long as you know for sure that you
want it and you want it really badly i
think
for me they're probably the main things
i would say that make a
highly successful recruiter i love that
so just for context for people listening
we're just talking a bit about this but
just for
context cole could you just sort of
share like the world that you've
t you've recruited in over the last sort
of six years i know it's been on a bit
of a transition recently but
like just give us a bit of a flavor of
the typical people that you'd be placing
and have been supporting and then that
will just help with context
yeah sure so as you mentioned it is has
transitioned a little bit but what has
never changed is that it's always been
around
placing the best entry level so junior
and graduate talent
into recruitment businesses or more
recently into fast-growing tech
businesses
mainly across manchester and london so
people are very much looking to enter
a sales-based career for the very first
time amazing
and then the reason why i wanted to
share that is because
yeah i think straight away with what you
just said on your last point there like
really clear on what people want
i was just interested to just dig a bit
deep in there straight away like
in your experience and the sort of lens
that you
sort of see it from has that changed i
think a lot of people online
particularly around recruitment right i
think a lot of people online um
say the the money part that's changed
but i don't know i had someone on the
other week and a lady
called dan dan in new york and like
obviously it's different nuances
but like she was on the completely
different scale like for her
people need to know or want recruitment
to be a financial
wealth vehicle for them to achieve what
they want to so i wanted to ask you that
straight away like do you
do you feel that has changed
yeah i actually listened um to a bit of
that episode as well um
has it changed yes it's probably what i
would say
um now do you have to have an element of
money motivation and recruitment i think
you do
um the job is is too difficult
too much under pressure to do it if you
weren't motivated by money but i think
there are certain things that have maybe
overtaken money as a motivator or
certainly things that are important
particularly for graduates looking to
get into this role so
progression is key and graduates now
they always want to be improving they
always want to be
progressing financially but also in
their job title their responsibility
they want to be empowered
so i'd say progression um you know is
really important now in potentially
overtaking money
but a lot of people and what's changed
over the last few years is more and more
graduates
they want to be a part of almost
something that's bigger than them
they want to wherever they work they
want to have a purpose
they want to make sure whatever they are
doing they're getting better and
achieving every day
but they're part of something that's
having a bigger and greater impact so
to come back to your question i think
things have changed slightly
of course money's always going to be i
don't think we'll ever come away from
money being a motivator
um i think there are certainly things
that are more important
than they probably were five six years
ago when i first started
yeah yeah really interesting so let's
let's break this down then so like carl
how would you describe your first year
in recruitment
um wow i'm going to give you like a few
a few stories here but it was um
it was amazing like some of the
experiences i got fresh out of the
university
joining a startup business not knowing
what was what was this is prime when you
joined like how yeah described this as
prime
um it was a pink logo
wow okay was you their first hire
yeah the first higher so
it was a website and it was an idea a
great idea and a concept
that was it and so the mission and the
journey was to make this concept to
reality so
zero candidates and i mean zero there
was no database at the time
no clients we didn't have a single
client so
what it was like it was difficult it was
tough but
that was part of the reason i joined in
the first place because i wanted that
excitement i wanted to be a part of
something
you could help grow and it kind of
brings back to what we just referred to
with that
purpose i suppose and being part of
something that mattered to me
and the exposure and the experience you
would gain just as much
as the money that you could earn during
recruitment so
let's give you an example when we first
started um when i first started
resourcing
you know forget sauce break all these
amazing tools and things do your job we
had
like a three-day trial of seabree
library to kick things off
and get as many series as possible yeah
remember yeah exactly so
it was tough but you look back on it now
and it was such a humbling and grounding
experience at the time so yeah it was
basically taking a concept
taking it to market and proving it could
work which six and a half years on
uh we're not where we want to be but you
know we've certainly done very well
yeah no absolutely um love that so i
guess
just thinking about it doesn't have to
be specifically for the
first year but early on in your
recruitment career which as you all know
probably better than most is is
typically the the toughest
and where a lot of recruiters can end up
spinning out of recruitment or
recruitment sort of tune them up and
spit them back out so
i guess what um what were some of the
the biggest challenges for you then
in those sort of first year year or so a
couple of years like what
so you just said that yeah he was
ultimately selling a concept and
starting from the ground up but so what
were some of the biggest challenges that
you had to overcome early on
yeah loads so um one of the biggest
challenges was probably
competition at the time um you know we
were speaking to candidates and
we were quite limited early on with the
options that we had for these candidates
to send out
so our competition just um had so much
more power in the market so the big
challenge was we were missing out
on more candidates we were placing at
the beginning so i think that was a
really big challenge because
you're investing so much time into
people as you know we provide
training to candidates at this level as
well to invest
all of that time for little or no return
whatsoever i think that was a
that was a massive challenge in itself
um
i think just being on the phone
in a role where you're the only person
that's just starting doing this
particular job where you don't have
people to
to bounce off you know a lot of people
going into a bigger recruitment business
you've got
so many people there that you can learn
off and speak to on a daily basis
um you know we didn't have that at the
beginning because it was a startup so
they're just two of the challenges but
um
through all of the challenges there were
they've also been great experiences and
reasons
why i wouldn't have had it any other way
at the same time yeah i think just on
if we could just just sort of zoom in on
that point where he said around
yeah like there was i'm obviously um
there were you start
you joined the business there's people
that you could look up to and
yeah neil nicole obviously driving the
business but i guess
what i wanted to zoom in on that point
of light and i'm not having as many
people that maybe people are used to
bouncing off and these types of things
i think that that's been really apparent
over the last year right
where obviously you're joining me today
from from home
and i think that's something that um is
really relevant over the last year where
i've i've spoken to numerous recruiters
who
yeah got their bd power hour or spending
two three hours doing bd
and like yeah been rejected numerous
times and
sometimes you can use that office
environment to bring you back up
so i guess how have you how has that
translated for you over the last year on
that point because i'm sure that that's
obviously changed
for you how have you ended up bouncing
back or making sure that you remain
motivated
despite you just smashing it out from
your dining room table on your own or
whatever
um so this year in particular um
i don't know i think i've probably
learned very early on in my career
um you always have to know what you're
aiming for and what you're striving for
so the first few weeks of the last 12
months were obviously very difficult
because
kind of you just ripped up ripped up the
textbook so to speak but
i think very quickly we just realigned
our focus
focus sorry i knew what i wanted to
achieve and what i needed to achieve
and that just kept me motivated you know
being working at home over the last six
to nine months
um it's still not non-comparable to what
prime was like in the early days
because if anything it's been better
although we still have zoom
and all these ways to communicate with
people that's more than we probably did
have
at the beginning so for me personally
it's been fine i know for others it has
been a challenge it's not been easy
working in a sales role when you're at
home in your bedroom having to make
you know cold calls to businesses for
recruiters probably more so than ever
because
bd all of a sudden became the big focus
overnight
i think it has been incredibly
challenging for most people
i think i was maybe a little bit more
fortunate that i've already been
conditioned or preconditioned you've had
those experiences
yeah so so i guess what people want to
know
and and you can refer to any point in
your career but like what people want to
know on this point
is like when have you been in like a
real slump or like where
i don't know whenever you experience
like just haven't got any wins or
haven't sort of
moved the needle in any part of your
recruitment desk over a period of time
keep getting rejected keep getting
pushed back maybe i had a number of drop
outs but i don't know like when have you
been in real estate maybe in the last
year or i don't know when
have you been in that sort of space and
how have you sort of typically got
yourself out of that to push on and
and sort of um do what you need to do
which is what you're talking about now
yeah there's there's been loads loads of
examples and i think as you
transition and progress through your
recruitment career those
challenges and those slumps they're just
different i think when you first start
becoming a recruiter is to do a dropout
i think when you then become a manager
it's more to do with how people in your
team are feeling
and how they're performing and how
they're doing so i think it changes
a big one that really sticks out for me
it was quite funny when i look back on
it now
i was on holiday uh me and my girlfriend
were in the
amalfi coast in italy um which is not
been recommended beautiful place
um but it is quite expensive it's not
cheap when you're over there and
whilst i was over there um there was
the thing between there was definitely
two potentially a third
dropout or deal that didn't go in that i
was counting on for commission that was
due to be paid
whilst i was in italy oh that was
happening
i knew what was um i knew what was going
on i was asking neil for updates and
he wasn't being particularly quick to
respond i know this is bad news
um so that cost me it cost me a
significant
amount of commission that was due to
receive whilst i was over there so
that was a real swamp because in a time
when you mentioned the time of your life
knowing that things that have happened
back in the uk
somewhat out of your control are going
to cost you x amount of money
um so that was difficult how did it
bounce back at the time i just had the
mindset
i'm not going to wait during my holiday
um you know there's nothing there's
nothing
i'm sure yeah you had the other half
saying as well like carl i can't have
you being miserable like go have your
strop and then come back
yeah no she yeah she was certainly in my
ear quite a bit um
but yeah i was i just had the mindset i
can't control it now there's nothing
that i can do and
um that's kind of the mindset i've
always had if
if there is something that i could have
done to change a situation
i'll get quite frustrated about it like
why didn't i do that but right this is
what i need to do next time
if there's a situation like that that
happened whilst i was away
if there's nothing that i can do at a
moment in time there's no point letting
it impact your day
and how you're feeling so that's just
one example that particularly stands out
there's obviously been loads but that
was one in particular where
you know it's um it sticks in the memory
it hurts but it still hurts
yeah so i guess on on this point then
like
obviously you would you would have
helped countless people
and start their careers in recruitment
like what
like where do you think people typically
go wrong or like where do you
why why do you think a lot of recruiters
do end up failing and then do end up
leaving the industry i don't know where
because obviously the turnover can be
quite high can't it and um so
i don't know where do you think sort of
people typically go wrong early on in
their recruitment career that can
sometimes leave them
either really struggling or then end up
leaving the industry
what comes up for you in that i think
a lot of the times it's that people
going into it don't know what to expect
i think that is the most common reason
people go into recruitment
not fully understanding exactly what
they will be doing day to day
and how difficult it can be which is one
thing that i try to do in the
conversations i have with
graduates looking to get into sales or
recruitment is
really giving them a warts and all
overview of exactly look
these are the great things we can talk
about that all day long
but what are you going to find difficult
other people find this difficult how
will you deal with that
um they're the best that we focus on so
i think the most common reason people go
wrong is they don't know exactly what
they're getting themselves in for
and i think i would kind of flip this as
well and i think any graduate looking to
go into this industry
it is a partnership graduates are
responsible for making sure they've got
the right motivations for knowing what
they want to do
us as business leaders we're also
responsible for making sure we give
these people the platform the training
and support to be successful so i think
you know why a lot of people don't work
out i think it is twofold
but the most common one is people not
truly understanding
what it is they're getting themselves in
for yeah
yeah really good point and and i guess
just
like sort of on that point um
do you think on that do you think it has
got better that sort of the i don't know
like i don't know would you
i don't know what the actual stat is i
should probably know it but do you think
the sort of
people that do enter the recruitment
industry think more people actually stay
in the industry now or
less because i feel like i mean this is
part of the reason why i started the
podcast but i think
when i looked to enter the industry in
2016 i wanted to work in the industry
because a friend told me about it but he
just sent me the dream
um like there was limited content there
was like limited stuff online like you
just
saw like the potential earnings and
stuff like that but obviously there's
just so much content out there now
but like you said it's a partnership and
i think it's important that one
grad know what they're going into but
then also are they in the invite are
they an environment that
is going to support them or is going to
just set them up to sink and fail
do you think it has improved
um i can confidently speak about
candidates that we've represented and
worked with and it
definitely has um you know that there
has been a change and
more and more people are being
successful and sticking in their roles
and
our mission and it hasn't changed our
purpose is to change the perception of
sales so
what we want is graduates when they come
to their third and final year where they
finish university is
they know what a career in sales is it's
not something they fall into
it's not just something that you know
the friend tells them the dream about
like you mentioned it's something they
are
already aware of um and i think doing
that
and you know we have influenced that
over the last few years but i think
continuing to do that
and change that perception will
definitely be something that improves
the retention rate
if these people know what they're
getting themselves in for nothing's a
surprise nothing's a shock so they're
much more likely to then stick it out
and you know stay in it for years to
come
so to answer your question has it
improved yes
but there is definitely still work to do
i think there is still an assumption
by a lot of sales leaders that they will
hire people and
some will work out and and some won't we
want to change that but the people that
don't work out you know
they're not the rule they're the
exceptions more people should work out
but not definitely
yeah no i love that that's really
interesting so the next thing i just
wanted to ask you on this sort of point
on
sort of early on in sort of recruiters
careers and stuff and then
we'll transition into you being a leader
in these types of things but
like a question i've had a couple of
times obviously a lot of recruitment
businesses rely on hiring trainees
right and i know that you guys hire
trainees yourself
right if that's grads non-grads or
whatever but a question i've had a
couple of times
which i'll be interested to get your
thoughts on is like how
can managers and leaders help sort of
graduates or people earning their
recruitment career like
really deal with self-doubt and i've
just had that question quite a lot where
yeah
they hire um a group of grads or new
people who just really struggle to
believe that they can do the job or
really suffer that self-doubt early on i
don't know one of you experienced that
too
any thoughts on how you think managers
and leaders can sort of impact
that self-doubt that sort of people
earlier than their criminal career may
have
um i think we've all experienced that i
think anyone who says they haven't at
some point had some sort of
self-doubt is you know is probably lying
um what
can we do as managers and leaders is
just manage that effectively so
um give examples of things that people
have done previously most of the time
self-doubt is just a belief that you
have it that is incorrect it's not
actually true it's just something that
you
you
believe to be true but i think it's our
job as leaders just to
unlock that mindset find out why they're
thinking that way
in the first place um uncover it a
little bit more and just help them and
guide them i think that's all we we can
really do
i mean there is a key here though um
having the right mindset i think is you
know having the right motivation
definitely something you either have
or you don't others managers just need
to you know give guidance
um and leadership when they may be
having a little bit of doubt but i don't
think we should be necessarily giving
loads of motivation i think we need
people
are self-motivated in this particular
role yeah
and then just find a point on this like
you hear a lot of people
now talk about they need sort of
recruiters to have that growth mindset
wherever they are in their career but i
guess particularly early on if you can
make sure that
you're hiring people that do have that
then then that could be
yes because then you're having this
mindset of life what can i learn from
this failure challenge blah blah blah
but how have you how have you actually
looked for that in graduates or
junior sales talent like how have you
identified if people have a growth
mindset out of interest
yeah good good question and it is
difficult and when speaking
to clients all the time the big
challenge they have is
interviewing entry-level candidates
because they've never done the job
before so it's not like if you're
interviewing an experienced sales people
you can just say look you know what have
you delivered what have your targets
been what have you achieved against them
um but it is just looking at what
they've done in their life whether that
be work
education extracurricular stuff and
trying to get them to give you examples
of where they have
demonstrated a growth mindset it's as
simple as that and um although these
people won't have worked in sales or
recruitment before
they will have done a lot of things in
their life where they will have
demonstrated the ability
to grow um so it's just unlocking that
and seeing
seeing where they have it but it could
be in anything and i remember one
example we had a client where
they wanted people that were high
performers and again a
graduate level you know that can be
difficult to find um and people
you know they're always looking to grow
but they weren't bothered about
what that was and so much so we placed
um placed the candidate who
his high performance was in football
veterinary so he was only an amateur
football refereeing
but he got all his coaching badges and
was the top level that he could be at
that time as being a football referee
that is demonstrating growth that's
investing himself to get the badges
and i think there's an assumption that
um recruiters have to be incredible at
sports
not necessarily this person was a
referee and a very good one and
demonstrated
they wanted to grow and progress within
that particular field so
hopefully that helps around the houses
answer but hopefully it gives some
context into the types of things you can
look for when hiring at this level
yeah yeah no no absolutely and i think i
guess
what i just wanted to um ask you then is
what how old was you when you when you
entered the recruitment industry
21 21
yeah so that's my sort of final question
on this early days like what what advice
would you give
the 21 year old carl
entering recruitment industry just
joined this is prime startup
what would you say to them um
don't be afraid to make mistakes yeah
go go out and make mistakes that's the
advice i gave a lot of the guys in our
team now is
just go out and make mistakes okay don't
make the same mistakes again and again
make sure you learn
from them quickly but just go out try
things give things a go if you get it
wrong
so what we'll learn from it and make
sure we uh we improve for next time
yeah and i think that's that's that's
exactly that is it's like give yourself
at least the opportunity to make the
mistake
rather than not even getting in the box
to make the mistake you know what i mean
because then once you're in the box and
you're
trying to trying to get it in the goal
or whether you're there's things that
you can learn and then hopefully give
you the better chance of
getting more out of it when you do get
in the box next time do you know what i
mean
um so i love that so so just
just for context in class spoken a lot
about graduates early on
including yourself so just just to help
me out and people listening so obviously
work to
this is prime for over six years
progressed to associate director
obviously joined when it was a um
startup
um what was your journey in the sense of
so how long was you like just a sort of
just a individual contributor just
worrying about your own buildings
and then when did you start
transitioning to managing just give me a
bit of context on that and then we'll
dive into a bit more of
cold turning into a leader and the
things that you've learned there
yeah sure so it was probably the first
two two and a half years where it was
mainly as an individual contributor
which was
initially as a resourcer before then
progressing and transitioning into a 360
consultant
and it's probably around two and a half
coming up to three years in where the
management responsibility started with
two people so we hired two resources
that i was responsible for and managed
um and then at that point it was just
about growing the team from there
yeah nice and then i'm assuming then as
you got more support
you was i guess you assuming you was
focusing on more client development
things like that and
you may be involved in the delivery side
but you'd get support on that side
exactly that so when we had the team
coming in responsible fulfilling roles
my
main two focuses and two priorities
really was new business development
and ensuring that the team had
everything they needed
from me to to be successful and achieve
what they were looking to achieve
yeah nice so look i think let's let's
just zoom in a bit on on the client
side like it is the most popular area
whenever
i speak to recruiters within recruitment
mentors are just in general
around sort of the area that like they
want to improve the most
it's always typically the client side
so if we just talk a bit about that for
a second
um i guess what over your career like
what has continued to be
the sort of best way for you to build
your
your client network and build business
and build client relationships with
people that
you do a lot of business with like what
continues to i know it could be a
multiple of things but like what
continues to be
the best way for you to build that
client side
you're so right by the way this is
incredibly popular at the moment like
every conversation that we're having
with
people in our networks is all around um
business development and winning new
clients so it's become more popular now
than ever
and what's worked really well for me is
the first 18 months of my career where
we were speaking to candidates that we
couldn't place yeah i think i mentioned
earlier we were
losing out on more candidates we were
placing at the very very beginning
that for me was and still is the best
way
to generate new business and really
build your network so there was
candidates we were missing out on
that went on to become managers within
their businesses that are now some of
our biggest clients
but very early on in my first few months
there were candidates that we missed out
on
so we did get a return it just took a
few years to do that so for me
the best client development strategy is
just delivering incredible experiences
for every single person that you speak
to
whether that's giving no feedback to a
candidate make sure it's the most
relevant and best feedback that you can
give them that helps them moving forward
because that person you never know who
they
may know or they could become themselves
so
it's probably away from the usual answer
of videos cold calling referrals
kind of referrals but it's that when you
first start in your recruitment career
those first 18 months are absolutely key
because you're speaking to so many
different people that
will be in your network there's probably
key decision makers
within a matter of years if they're not
already so for me that that was the key
that is still the best
um you know candidates that we've worked
with at prime that go on to become
managers themselves they're our biggest
advocates and our biggest ambassadors um
another point on that is just being
different um
i think where a lot of recruiters go
around that go wrong sorry it's still
being quite transactional in what they
do
not really necessarily caring about what
they're doing it's just you know i need
to get x amount of specs out
or i need to speak to x amount of
decision makers i think
what's worked well for me is having a
purpose for the businesses that i'm
trying to bring on there's a reason that
i want to work with this business
whatever that may be
so yeah along with the first the first
date two years the key
in terms of the relationships you
develop and the reputation you build for
yourself
that can be quite difficult to change so
it's important you nail that early on
and then just making sure when you're
reaching out to people and trying to win
new business
you know why you want that client and
how they fit in
with kind of your brand and your network
yeah i love that second point
i guess what you're talking about there
carl is is basically having this
long-term mindset
right so i guess early on
it can be hard to have that connect
because
for different reasons like i might work
for you and you're going i need you to
get x number of
deals in or whatever like so i might be
facing some internal pressures
but i'm going you know what yeah but i'm
playing the long game like i know that
over the next 18 24 months like this
could really come to fruition so i guess
i don't know like how how have you
cultivate that yourself a lot how have
you
gone about cultivating that long-term
mindset in your teens because not
everyone has that
and that could be for different reasons
it could be yeah like i said because
they've got to keep their manager happy
or because they want they want the deals
in this month i don't know how how have
you cultivate that yourself and how have
you
cultivated that in in the people that
you've managed
how i've cultivated it in myself was
when i first joined the business it was
always with the long term
in mind if it wasn't with the long term
in mind i wouldn't have joined a startup
as the first person
so for me it was already embedded
because i knew it was going to be a
journey
it wasn't just going to be something
that you did in short-term blocks
so that was already embedded how to then
embed that in the team
we've got success stories and examples
of things that have happened
due to us caring about the relationships
we were building in the early days so
it's quite easy to reinforce to our team
because we can say
if you do this if you provide amazing
experiences if you do this
this is what you will eventually get in
return
from your network they will end up
approaching you just by you doing all of
this really well
in the early days at the beginning of
your career and i think that was
embedded
um a lot by you know neil nicole to be
fair as well early on the importance of
making sure every single candidate has
feedback making sure regardless of what
we can do with them they have an amazing
experience so
that's just something that's embedded in
the organization anyway and
from a personal perspective was was
always in it for the long term
yeah now that's really interesting and i
think i guess if you're listening to
this and
you haven't got a manager that's saying
giving you these examples i i guess if
you're listening to this like go and
find those examples
like if you're sort of listening to this
and like no not sure like i can wait
that long or whatever well
are some of the sort of high performing
builders in your team
you should have at least a couple that
you could look up to
and ask them like out of interest out of
your sort of five best clients like
where did they come from and
there might be a story in there right
that you're sharing it's like right okay
yes and that can reinforce that can't
that
so go and find that in your business if
you if you're not being told it like
going
hopefully if you listen to this podcast
you've because we hear this a lot about
the importance of long-term
relationships not being transactional
but
if you need that again that those
examples just try and find them in your
business
yeah they definitely will be there and
look don't be reliant on this you know
don't
um try and leverage your relationships
from your first year in the business and
never pick up the phone and do a cold
call of course you should be doing that
as well
but it is it's an easy way that people
sometimes
overlook yeah yeah for sure so on
on this on this point on client
development and you sharing
that sort of been some of the best ways
just out of interest it's one of the
popular things that people
always want to know about um what what
does carl's
maybe you can refer to when you're just
an individual contributor or more now
but like
what does a typical day look like for
you people don't know day plans people
want to know
how does cole what does carl's typical
day look like to ensure that
you're hitting your quota or you think
that gives you the best
chance of getting the deals that you
need to each month what does a day plan
look like for you
yeah um again it's it is different every
single day so
i'll try and give you an idea of a
typical day but you know yeah
it does obviously change um you know now
in the in the role that i'm in but
typically let's say monday um
first bit of the day will be spent with
the people in my team going through one
to one's review of performance last week
what we need to do to improve going into
this week we try and keep that more
um improvement and kind of you mentioned
it before growth mindset focus
so yeah we look at numbers but we look
at the reasons behind them and okay what
do we need to be doing differently or
what can we do to improve going into
this weekend so that's what monday
morning would typically start off with
um then for me a lot of the day will be
um business development focused so
that's a key area for me now in looking
to build
prime brand um in the uk outside of
manchester and london and in the us too
so that will be very much structured um
the next couple of hours
early afternoon the uk business
development which will be
split into blocks of time depending on
the activity or outreach that i'm doing
and then later on in the afternoon we'll
obviously be more u.s focused uh due to
the time difference but again
what we try and do is block it out into
specific times so
this week we'll have three um bd you
know cold calling sessions
and then the sales team may do an hour
where we get together and write all
we're doing is personalized videos for
this hour
then what we're doing is linkedin voice
notes so that kind of answers your
question we block things out in time so
that in that time period
everything you do can be focused on that
particular
activity so yeah that's what my day
looks like managing the team and
i'm trying to create and win new
business opportunities
and you know thank you for sharing that
i guess
what what i wanted to ask you is like
how important
is the is the is the part in your diary
like before you get to those block times
to get one in
i think that's where sometimes people go
wrong where sometimes people share the
non-negotiable for them is that they've
done the plan
so they have a plan when they go into
that block time do you go i mean so how
much time do you spend on
mapping out or when you do go into that
session with your team
you know where you're sort of putting
your energy into do you get my
yeah yeah definitely um that probably
comes into the night before
um so what i like to do every single day
before properly switching off is
just do like a little wrap up with
yourself really on right what have we
done today
what is tomorrow's focus and what do we
need to achieve um
helps you sleep better at night as well
when you're going to bed knowing exactly
what you've done and what you need to do
yeah so that that helps um how much time
goes into planning it
it's difficult to kind of put a time on
it but i would always make sure going
into these
particular blocked out areas of course
you have to have done your preparation
beforehand
to make the most of the time there's
nothing worse than going into a
you know a business development hour
whatever it is you may be doing
if 20 minutes between each call we spend
researching and
you know doing what you need to do
beforehand in between every call it's
just
it's not the best use of that time so
yeah the preparation's always done
and most of the time it will be done the
evening before
if it's specific to that day it will be
done again on on the morning before you
actually start
start and sit down at your desk for the
day yeah and and you mentioned
you do different things as team teams
but like
is cold calling dead
[Laughter]
no you see so many people talking about
this
well actually it is dead because no
one's doing it
but that doesn't mean it's dead if there
is a time we had this in a bit of an
internal session this morning so i might
be
sharing a few secrets cold calling is
absolutely alive
and those who are not doing it now are
losing out um
we you know the directors at prime for
example the people that
we get sold to all the time there is so
many emails and linkedin messages that
we're receiving
we've not got any cold calls on our
mobiles there's been not one cold call
whatsoever
landlines yeah you know maybe there has
been but no one's really been in the
office
so no cold calling is not dead if there
is a time
to be doing cold calling it is now but
i'm a believer and you should always be
doing the thing that makes you stand out
so we still do videos i'm not saying you
know they're not good
same with linkedin voice notes really
well crafted cold outreach emails
the issue is a lot of people are doing
them
no one else is cold calling so as long
as you can do a cold call
you are standing out just by doing that
you don't have to be mega creative with
it just by doing it
you're going to be standing out because
no one else is doing it so
no it's it's not it's dead but it
shouldn't be
and my advice to anyone listening to
this is
just pick up the phone cold call people
invest in a tool that allows you to get
people's mobile numbers working from
home
just speak to people yeah and i think
look i think the message here because
i've seen this time and time again and
it's like what carl's saying
is one cold calling shouldn't be your
only method of getting hold of people
that's that's number one i think
sometimes people
put cold calling in that camp of like
okay if you're cold
and then you're only doing cold call
ends you know what i'm in so it's like
one it shouldn't be your only method
carl's mentioned around voice notes
video message outreach like
all those things so i think it's like
what can you do
i think the better way to sort of think
about cold calling or that initial
outreach is like what can you do
that could give you a better chance of
these people knowing who you are
and and giving you a better chance of
standing out to that person before you
call that mobile
number do you know what i mean um
because that can hopefully mean that
you have a better chance of getting
those 30 to 90 seconds to explain why
you're calling and how you might be able
to help help them and add value to them
um so it's like what can you do to warm
up that cold call
do you know what i mean i think that's
the better question isn't that
dude definitely um and there's certainly
a place for that as well and
um using different approaches but i
think you've got to be clever with it um
and i think what recruitment probably
does need to do
and it's starting to do it is treat
itself we've always said recruitment is
sales
but there's a lot of things that recruit
but sales people do that recruiters
don't necessarily do so to give you an
example i think you need to be clever
with your outreach because different
things will work for different people
so a couple of real recent real life
examples the client that we bought on
um we're advertising had a job spec up
online and in that job spec
specifically what they were looking for
was someone who loved the phone the
telephone will be this person's best
friend
so if we didn't cold call that business
how can we expect for them to work with
us so literally
picked up the phone this is a cold call
you know you've said in your your job
ads you want people that love the phone
this is the only way i could introduce
myself
we brought the client on another one was
a tech business selling to someone that
was probably trying to be more creative
in their own sales job
sent them a video and that resulted in a
meeting and agreeing terms so
i think that the advice is just be
clever with it but certainly incorporate
cold calling
into what you do yeah i love that and
you're using
you're just being smart there and like
playing yeah
utilizing what these companies are
trying to get for their own businesses
and yeah
i love that that's that's great um
so let's talk a bit about it's always a
sort of common challenge that recruiters
face i'm sure you've had to learn the
hard way and learn as you go like
what's been your journey a lot with
leadership and and sort of managing
people's performance whilst managing
your own
what's the journey been like um it's
just eye-opening to begin with because
you go from being
so so individually focused
so in control you know individually of
what you you're going to achieve
to very quickly everything being based
on the team and of course you are in
control
but there are certain things that maybe
happens in your team that means you
don't get to where you want to be or
you don't achieve your goals so it's
eye-opening it is a challenge for sure
um what's my journey been like with it
is
just focusing where i find my
achievement and my motivation so i just
very quickly had to realize
that there's no point me i was focusing
more on the team performance in my own
villains
if my personal billing suffered i wasn't
bothered if it meant
the people in my team were helping
achieve the collective goal
i think that's the the short answer is
um
i was quite fortunate in the way that i
was being managed was more focused on
the team goal
and you know if i had to contribute to
help us achieve that i would
but it was more focused on what your
team needs to do this if that means you
can
sacrifice your personal billings for the
greater good of the team then so be it
we're absolutely fine with that
so yeah i hope that helps me i just had
to shift my mindset to
write i need to now find sense of
achievement in
us doing this as a collective as we're
great not any one individual is
yeah nice and that definitely is a
mindset shift isn't it when you've
only had to worry about yourself um
i guess we may have already touched on
it but sort of thinking about
sort of you as a leader and looking at
it from a leadership side like where
i know i'm always interested to answer
ask yourself so you would have managed
number of people now like where do you
think sort of recruiters typically go
wrong the
or the typical stumbling block blocks or
the typical hurdles that
they always end up tripping over that
can sometimes prevent them from
maximizing their potential that you know
that they can hear i don't know what
what sort of common things have you
always seen or
seen happen out of interest and the
self-doubt thing that you mentioned
earlier is
is quite common and i think that's why
it's important we look for people that
are solution
focused so we always used to have a bit
of a joke in
in our team um where someone would say
or
i don't know how to do this or i can't
do this or this isn't working for me and
we just and it got to a point where this
was so embedded that
i didn't even have to say it other
people in the junior people on the team
would
say it was we want solutions not
problems and then we'd work together
ask questions and we don't want oh this
isn't working i can't do that right
that's fine
things don't work but we need to work as
a collective to overcome it and get the
result that we want
so self-doubt i think is the biggest
thing that stops
recruiters definitely but i think again
it's just a mindset piece of making sure
that you're always looking for solutions
and outcomes to problems rather than
focusing on the problems too much
themselves
so that definitely helped the myself and
and the people in our teams
and it's something something that we
still say and call people out for now
there's no such thing as you know you
can't do something it's okay you can't
now but what do we need to implement and
help you with
so you can find a solution to it um
self-doubt
self-doubt is definitely a big big one
but i think it is relatively
easy to coach and train um if you've got
the right people in the first place
for sure um and what else
again linked into self-doubt but it is
business development a lot of people
when they transition from the resources
to consultant level
struggle are scared of business
development um
and bringing on clients so again we we
just try and embrace it
as something that you should relish
something that you should actually enjoy
and
you should look forward not necessarily
to the rejection but there are parts of
that you should should embrace for sure
yeah again bit of a a worthy answer but
hopefully there's a couple of pieces in
there that do
it mainly does come down to mindset if
you've hired the right people with the
right skill set
more often than not mindset is the only
thing that stops them
yeah not really interested in that and i
guess
just on this it may tap into mindset but
i think this is
something that you've probably had to
get good at as well and i think sort of
great managers have had to really step
up and understand like
i like you always hear around motivating
your team and things like that i guess
what's been how do you think you've sort
of got the best out of your team i'm
always interested to hear how
managers and recruitment leaders have
they think done that how have you sort
of got the best out of your team and
motivated your team do you think
understanding i think is is key um
really understanding the people in your
team and what motivates them so
although we're working towards a team
collective to to achieve something
what motivates person x and the reason
they're doing it could still be very
very different
and completely different to person life
so i think as a manager you have to
understand the people in your team on a
personal level
and you have to understand why they're
in it why are they doing what they're
doing if you don't understand that as a
manager
you've probably got no chance so to come
back to your question how to get the
most and motivate your team
you just have to understand them you
know it's just simple it's as simple as
that
um and it does does get overlooked which
is why our kind of weekly one-to-ones
are
so important there's so much more than
just uh how many calls did you make last
week you know there's so much more than
that
it's kind of an ongoing development
session of really understanding the
people you're working with
so you can then get the best out of them
yeah i love that and we've heard it
a lot on this podcast but like you said
it it's probably
overlooked and i think sort of thinking
of the conversations that i've had with
leaders over the last sort of three to
six months there's
um they've always shared the same thing
which is like
the meetings that they have what you're
talking about like we don't talk about
numbers
i mean that isn't to say that you
shouldn't know you shouldn't have kpis
and stuff like we need to know what the
recipe is to get to
where you need to right we need to know
are we on track are we not blah blah
blah but
like if if you're if your meetings with
your guys and girls are just about
like you said how many calls they have
blah blah blah then
yeah you're going to struggle to get the
most out of them
so it's just really common and and it
comes up a lot so
thank you for sharing that i guess what
i wanted to ask you carl before we
sort of finish and come towards the end
here a lot of recruiters that i've
spoken to you said one of the big
motivators is progression and i think a
lot of
sort of aspirational recruiters that
want to sort of really
make the most out of their recruitment
career want to get to where you've got
to if that's a director or whatever the
title is so i guess
you could say on paper that carl was
destined to get
to that point and get the opportunity to
potentially
own part of the business or sit at the
board because he was the first hire but
i think there'll be a lot of people that
may not maximize that opportunity or may
not be in the position that you are so i
guess what i wanted to
hear from you was like why do you think
you was
you've been able to really grasp that
opportunity and get to where you've got
to and hopefully even
in the future and part of the business
and these things like why do you think
he was able to do that
and not some of the people that maybe
joined at a similar time or could have
got that as well
yes it is a really really interesting
point um
but probably certainly one of self
reflection a little bit i think the
perception might be you know first one
in their business as you said that's
been
destined for that to happen but there
are people who have joined the business
not too long after that had experience
that
you know were probably better positioned
um to actually fast track
and get to director quicker than i have
um
that didn't for for one reason or
another so i think the key things are
knowing what you want to achieve i think
any advice i would give to someone
that's listening that wants to become a
director
is first of all make sure it is what you
actually do want to achieve
and secondly be really forthcoming with
your ambitions
don't hold back you know i've always
made it clear to the guys at prime that
that is where i want to get to and at
any one time you could have asked me
what do you need to do to get your next
promotion or
how long go away are you roughly from
getting a direct so i could have told
you at any one time this is what i need
to do
this is what i need to generate this is
how many clients need to bring on be the
competencies
i need to work on and develop so at any
one time i could have told you
and i think anyone out there that wants
to become a director if we were to ask
you what do you need to do to get
promoted what do you need to do to get
the next step
you should know the answer to that
question if you don't you need to go and
find the answer straight away
so i think that's the key thing really
and knowing what it is you need to do
and achieve and being really forthcoming
with it i think is is absolutely key and
then
the third one is make sure you join the
right business and
um bit of a disclaimer that isn't
necessarily a startup
um there are so many examples out there
of bigger businesses where people have
joined and become a director in
five six seven years so it doesn't have
to be a startup at all
but make sure you are joining the right
business if you do want to become a
director
um questions you should ask are just
very simply looking for people
that have already done that already
replicated that making sure again
even before you join join a business
what do i need to do to get to director
level so
yeah then hopefully there's a few few
bits of advice i think it comes down to
being in the right business
making sure you actually want it and
then make sure you know what you need to
do to get there
if you have them three things the rest
the rest is down to you really
and i think just to make this crystal
clear like in your opinion like how much
responsibility
lays on the person to find out what they
need to do like is that
is that something like is that that
should that should that be completely
down
to me to find that out or should that
should i expect the company to
tell me that it's a again it's a
partnership
um yeah i think i think the
responsibility
does lie with the company for sure but
then again
if i was to think well i'm going this is
my career and i don't know the answer to
these questions
i would make it my responsibility um so
i think it does lie with the company
but if the company doesn't provide
clarity on on that and believe it or not
there are
so many recruiters sales people i've
spoken to in the past that
you asked what their targets are or what
they need to achieve
they cannot tell you so it is a real
problem you know it's not just something
we're making up people don't know what
they need to do to get promoted and
you know quite a few businesses out
there so it's the company's
responsibility they should have a
framework a progression plan
everything in place if you as a
recruiter don't know that
make it your responsibility and if not
find
it yeah yeah yeah i love that that's
what i want you to highlight there is
the
okay so if if the business doesn't have
all the answers like take it upon
yourself to one try and find out the
answers and if they don't then it's like
okay well
like you said it's a partnership what
let's talk about that like this is i'm
telling you this is where i want to get
to
what what do you need me to do to get
there or at least consider me for that
so
and i think those questions that you
outline there's such great questions to
know
about yourself and and your recruitment
career do you know what i mean
like i think yeah so i think that's
really
great advice um so i wanted to before i
asked you the
five final questions i wanna i wanted to
ask
um to get your sort of thoughts on like
a temperature of
the recruitment industry or like just
just sort of some of the trends that
you've noticed but before i do
i always like asking this question um
what do you think is like the most
important action or kpi that contributes
to
success in recruitment
that is the million dollar question
isn't it what is the most important
metric or kpi
um i'm going to challenge the
norm on this one and it's something that
we've started to recognize more and more
uh prime and i think it works well
because of the
market that we recruit into that has
typically had high retention
we measure and reward retention
now so our kind of quarterly
get-togethers we had a recognition and
award for
yeah highest revenue most of the
replacements but
the person that has had the best
retention of candidates placed
are you the ones that stayed in their
roles for the longest with the highest
percentage so
i would go as far to say in our industry
that's a really
important metric which i don't think
many
recruitment businesses probably place to
rewards
highlight put on yeah i love that yeah
so that that's what i would say probably
slightly different to the norm of course
you know there are a lot of metrics that
are important but for me in the industry
we're in
where the big challenge for entry level
is the retention rate
i think for us that has to be a key
metric
yeah and you know what like that metric
actually
fuels everything else like if you're if
you're a recruiter that
has got an amazing um stat around that
the
everyone i place has typically stayed
there for over two years or something
like that whatever
that also then helps you with everything
else that that's something that
you use incredibility and like the this
is something that you really care about
and something that
you can highlight when you're doing bd
and all these other things you get what
i mean so it's something that definitely
should be highlighted
and rewarded because yeah adds to just
proves the service that you're
delivering so
so yeah look before i ask you the five
final questions let you i know a bit of
a transition that
you definitely serve uh more now on the
sort of tech side but obviously being
involved in the recruitment industry for
some time supporting businesses
grow their business with entry-level
talent so look you've got obviously a
unique
lens on like what you're seeing what
you're not seeing
like i'll just be interested to hear
your thoughts really on like what
what are you keeping an eye on or how
are you feeling about the recruitment
industry
going into the sort of this year and the
next sort of two three four years what
do you think
some of the best companies are doing
where do you think maybe some companies
are
potentially going to be left behind i
don't know what comes up for you when i
say like the temperature of the
equipment industry and where it's going
how i'm feeling is excited i think
there's a big opportunity now
for a lot of businesses and it's
genuinely been really refreshing to hear
speaking to
um several recruitment business owners
recently that have posted record months
you know this year already you know even
you know
decimating pre-coded figures you know
it's really really impressive so i think
if anyone's in recruitment now
i would be excited about the future i
think how i
see it developing is businesses becoming
more
solutions focused whether that be with
partnerships exclusive models um you
know different recruitment processes
whatever that may be i see recruitment
becoming more solutions focused rather
than
the typical transaction of do you have a
job i will fill it
i think the businesses that will do the
best the ones that can
provide more than one solution to the
businesses that they partner with
um so that that's that's the way that i
see it going and i think for any
business that is doing that
more than just the typical filling jobs
i'd i'd be very excited
about what the next couple of years
could look like yeah i'm definitely
seeing the same so i think that's
amazing that you are seeing that as well
um okay five final questions
if if you could change the industry what
would you improve
so i've heard a lot recently that
there's and i've heard you discuss it as
well
about the low barriers to entry being
something that people would maybe change
i massively massively challenge and
disagree with that i actually think that
is one of the best things about the
recruitment industry
giving people with no experience the
opportunity
to earn really good money and develop
incredible careers
i think that's the best thing about the
recruitment industry
now the reason that that doesn't work
sometimes
is probably something that recruitment
business leaders people like myself
we need to look ourselves in the mirror
and go this isn't working
probably hiring these people if we're
not giving them the training and support
that they need
to be credible and you know to be really
good recruiters so
the thing that i would change is the
support
guidance and training and making sure
that we're setting people up to succeed
rather than setting them up to fail
that's something that's definitely
improved by the way
and is continuing to improve but for me
the low barrier barrier to entry
is probably the best thing one of the
biggest frustrations that a lot of
graduates have is that
i come out of the university and i
sometimes think that's
what they want yeah and so it's it's a
good thing
let's embrace it but we need to give the
correct support
training guidance leadership so these
people aren't just rubbing in the
headlights when they enter the industry
when they don't have the training and
support that's when you hear all the
horror stories
um that's where the human gets a bad
reputation
so yeah i wouldn't the barrier to entry
things it's not
i think that's a positive yeah and i
love that
um if you could write a linkedin post
that could be seen by every single
recruitment consultant across the world
what would you want it to say
i'm gonna have to say a disclaimer here
i've heard this saying
in this quote somewhere and i have
stolen it from someone and i don't know
who so if you're listening to this and
you're thinking i said that
yeah credit through um but it is
um don't take yourself too seriously
but take what you do very seriously i
think that really resonates with
particularly us at crime and that you
know we want to have fun with what we're
doing but
you know don't let that the traps from a
way that
we're incredibly serious about what
we're trying to achieve so
yeah don't take yourself too seriously
take what you do
very seriously yeah like that
what what did you spend your first
biggest commission paycheck on
uh i was in krakow on a lads weekend
away
at the time so it was um
yeah polish vodka um it's quite cheap
as well crack off so it's difficult to
spend a lot but we managed to try
and went to a wiggler crack off game in
the in a
stand with all the ultras as well so
basically just blew it on a last weekend
away
but it was incredible i love that final
question what
what's the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career
it's changed but for me now it's to
build
an incredible place for people to work
to ensure that the people within prime
have
everything they need to build successful
careers
and then to continue with our mission of
changing the perception of sales and
making sure that graduates see it as a
something that they choose to go into
not something they fall into i love that
car it's been an absolute pleasure
thank you thank you very much appreciate
it cheers